you know he's doing sit-ups you know
he's doing push-ups he playing
basketball he ordered pizza for the
people out there we said they're
training camp with just like you gotta
be kidding me
[Music]
coming on in my brother how you feel
let's see what's going on what's new
good how you doing a fool eight years
the years but I still about to dig into
you back a little bit from Chicago so we
like to get down yeah this is what you
knew the brick okay well I can make
something for a minute okay you know
Saddam it 2004 season right was a fourth
straight year you made it to the NFC
Championship game this time you came out
on top what was different about this
game against the Falcons we had some new
faces that weren't a part of those three
and we felt like those were the pieces
in Jevon Kearse and teal and Dorsey
Levens that got us over the hood and we
felt like we were just invincible that
year
you broke a barrier as well right you're
facing none of them Michael Vick first
time we had two black quarterbacks
facing off in the championship game the
first time ever in the NFL that there's
been two black quarterbacks facing each
other in order to achieve that one goal
and that's the make it to the Super Bowl
how significant is that for both of
y'all well and I looked at it more for
the future because they significant for
us but there's significant four kids
that were playing on the collegiate
level kids and I were playing in high
school kids that were playing and Pop
Warner because they gave them the
aspirations and the dreams that it could
come true you know what I can't play in
the NFL and I can make it to a Super
Bowl so Steve and I talked about when he
made it to Super Bowl and I wanted to be
the third it's such an important class
to be it with Doug Steve and I myself
what happened against the Patriots when
you were quarterback or any other
position do what got you there you know
try not to do too much I was trying to
be perfect and so some of the balls that
which I threw it obviously in it ends up
being intercepted and turnovers versus
New England just tough because they
always come back and capitalize leave
even if it's not a touchdown am I gonna
feel go
what a flip the field you know Tom and I
we talk talk every now and it you know
we've kind of talked about that and I
mean after that maybe they've won much
more yeah so it's like are you fine you
do so watching this Tom Brady in the New
England Patriots but you respect them
for that so when the game is over yeah
Patriots wins where you at I am out
there on the field because I felt like
we have been this close so many times we
finally got here we'll be back and I had
that confidence that the guys that I had
in locker room that we were gonna do
what we needed to do to get back to this
point to redeem ourselves I just felt
like you know what this is gonna happen
to me I think a lot of people they look
back at that game as well they recall
tío coming back what was that dynamic
like as he's coming back and then that's
that downfall from that what what
exactly happened well the lead-in to the
following year I'm thinking he'll be
back healthy you know we have free we
had guys that were just elevating their
game gaining experience we'll be back
and so the off season goes through and I
was in this turmoil hear their
conversation going back and forth and we
had to answer those questions instead of
focusing on what we need to do in order
to get back to where we were and I
thought that was the major distraction
for us you know he dose it up you know
he's doing push-ups he playing
basketball he ordering pizza for the
people out there and we said they're
training together just like you gotta be
kidding me cuz it's probably on would
you eat the cafeteria well not we you
know we're in our dorm rooms and you
know I'm just sitting there I'm watching
TV and Brian Dawkins a Trotter with Bob
Rubin and dolphin cover he's like man
what do you do now like take a look like
this is like days of our lives like it's
unbelievable but you know that was
something that kind of broke us up that
was the most frustrating for me because
I knew what we could do and if we
decided to just come together what would
be able to come you and T on talking
terms and what's the relationship like
now hey I give a nice b-side and keep it
moving
you know however you know I respect his
time you know I love my time you know it
there's no need for me to try to dust
off anything that happened in the
Packers what was in the passage in the
past you know he's made a few comments
you know as of late that's cool with me
listen I'm a grown man I have to grow
bad business thanks for kicking it with
us subscribe to be our to check out more
dope videos like this one